[Music]
welcome to the week in 60 minutes
brought to you by spectator tv
i'm katie balls the spectator's deputy
political editor
on this week's show we'll hear from a
former prime minister
a who envoy and a star roster of
spectator columnists
dr david nabarro will be joining from
geneva to tell us his thoughts on the
government's pandemic response
tony abbott the former prime minister of
australia joins from sydney
to weigh in on the new uk australia
trade deal and will also be joined by
spectator favorites rod liddle lionel
shriver and james forsyth to chat
everything from euros to 2021 and what
it's like to go abroad these days
remember to hit the subscribe button at
the bottom right of the screen to keep
up with the spectator's youtube channel
for free
and you'll be notified whenever a new
episode comes out
but first we're days away from june 21
but the anticipated freedom day has
perhaps unsurprisingly
been delayed was that the right decision
is
actually split opinion in the spectator
offices
i'm joined now by our editor fraser
nelson who argues that a delay is no big
deal
and k andrews edited the spectator's
daily lunchtime briefing
the only roundup of covered news and
analysis that you will need and she
takes a rather different view
fraser i hear you've got a slideshow
prepared after
a few days of disputes in the office
over everyone's views
well i wanted to show why i changed my
mind on this i mean for a long time
i was thinking that the data was showing
that britain had the lowest covert in
the whole of europe
that we had this thing licked certainly
the data seemed to show that
but when the facts change i guess any
journalists ought to change their minds
now we've got the highest
covert levels in europe and that's
because we've got the delta variant
whose behavior is actually very
different just like the
the kent variant so-called beta variants
that
certainly gave britain you might argue a
third wave or perhaps a second stint of
it
to the second wave but when the facts
change you've got to look at this now
what i want to show is what was quite an
influential graph
on me it's when we didn't actually run
the spectator because it's hypothetical
but last week's cover story we had um
philip thomas who's professor
of risk management at bristol university
now i've been following his modeling
because it's been a lot more on the
money than the various sage models we've
had
over the time now he basically asked a
question what if
the um the delta variance the india
variant
is 50 more transmissible his modeling
showed that when it came to deaths they
would be peaking far
fewer than the first wave so you could
certainly say that that was
um about you know in total there'd be 8
000 deaths
about as many as we're getting a week in
january and
similar to if at less than your standard
flu season so that was
about um obviously all the deaths are
tragic but
exit wave was always going to have these
deaths but what really gave me pause was
the graphs he was showing for infections
now if the delta variant was 50 more
infectious
those infections would absolutely surge
they'd be way higher than they were
in january we'll be looking at almost
three million infections a day perhaps a
bit more
now every one of these infections would
uh have so
that of than the social isolation you'd
have to stay at home
and your family members would stay at
home kids being sent home from school
now all of this would be happening on
the 21st of june when we lifted
restrictions so you'd have this
very dangerous juxtaposition of the
government saying
okay we're now free to abolish velazquez
the restrictions
and then a biggest surge in cases we'd
ever seen
now i've got a great belief that public
confidence
is one of the major things that's going
to get us back to normal the government
could abolish all restrictions tomorrow
and you wouldn't get traffic in london
back to what it was certainly in the
city where i go around right now you
still see restaurants
which are half empty um and these are
like in
the woolsey for example i was there for
breakfast until monday and the breakfast
at the world used to be something you
had to book
days if not weeks in advance now it's
still half empty as a lot of restaurants
simply because people like the
confidence
of going out as they once did
now it would not be good for confidence
if the government were to unlock
and then see absolute surging cases that
the government was struggling
to explain and the biggest question was
how sure can we be
that these surging cases three million
cases will not lead
to a bigger spike in deaths than we
predicted and with the delta variant we
had too little data we simply didn't
know
we didn't know last friday we know a
little bit more now the data is going in
the right
direction and i reckon in two weeks time
we'll know a lot more we might be able
to say with confidence with a lot more
confidence
that yes we will be able to stomach two
million three million more cases
and they simply will not translate into
hospitalizations because we've seen the
data we've done the sums
we know that but when we didn't know
that i couldn't see what was so
bad and waiting another two weeks given
that we waited 15 months
to get that more information and to be
able to come up to prepare the public
for the exit wave and i was arguing
months ago my telegraph column
but number 10 needed to start talking
about the exit wave that was inevitable
after lockdown ends so people would have
the confidence
and and that's still my position now i
still think this weight
hopefully it will just be a two-week
wait will give us time to see
how the the um information is going how
the data is going
and will give us more confidence to um
withdrawal
and end the rest of the restrictions
kate do you think the trade-offs are
worth it that bit of extra caution
um which means obviously not everything
returns to normal
and we can debate how much really has
returned to normal
um ultimately that is a trade-off worth
making
so i don't think we should assume it's
going to be two weeks i know fraser was
in support of a two-week delay but the
prime minister made it very clear in his
press conference that it's most likely
going to be four
and he wouldn't rule out a further delay
do i think it's worth it is almost the
wrong question what i've been asking
throughout this entire crisis and i
think was really the basis of where we
disagreed on the podcast
uh last friday which went out on
saturday
um is whether or not we can trust the
government to be completely honest with
us at the data we're looking at
if you want to make the case for caution
if you want to say we
just want to be absolutely sure that
that link between
infections and then hospitalizations and
sadly deaths is broken
and that way we can be completely
confident when we reopen in a few
more weeks that we can lift every single
restriction that social distancing can
go that mass can go and we can be free
again
i can see the case for it the problem is
that never
once has the government given us the
criteria that they're looking at and the
thresholds that they
are deciding in whitehall as to when the
data is safe to reopen
and it isn't just about this reopening
this was true in lockdowns last year it
was true of the tier system areas like
lester knew that
once they went into the tier system they
basically never came
out they've never been transparent about
the data
and the press conference actually made
me quite nervous i mean i i really hope
that we are now going to open up in
for i guess five weeks time on this new
date but they still
won't tell us what the threshold needs
to be they said where they hope they'll
be with two-thirds of the adult
population double-vaxxed and
with people over the age of 18 all
having their first dose but they didn't
say that was enough they didn't say
it was the criteria and i just am not as
optimistic or as forgiving of the
government as fraser has now
um quite dramatically in a relatively
big reversal decided
to be because we heard it was three
weeks to curb the virus last year then
it was 12 weeks to turn the tide i think
then in
the summer we were told the autumn was
looking good then in autumn we were told
that christmas would go ahead and then
at christmas we were
told that february would be looking
great and then in february we were given
a road map that didn't get us out till
the summer
and now we're delayed again and i know
that there are a lot of factors along
the way that change calculations fraser
is right when the data changes
you should change your mind the problem
is that we don't know what the data is
they still are not being transparent
about what they're willing to tolerate
and i think those grabs that fraser
showed are
really very interesting because we know
that
reopening society completely is going to
lead to a big
surge in cases there's no way it won't
and so if the government said we are
focused on hospitalization and death we
just want a bit more data
to that graph that fraser showed where
deaths hopefully don't come anywhere
near the peaks as they did in april or
january i
i understand that argument that makes
sense to me but fraser said he was
spooked by the cases and i think the
government
is spooked by the cases too and if
they're not following hospitalizations
and deaths and they're following cases
we're in a very difficult position
where we're going to see cases go up and
yet they don't want to see cases go up
and that means that it's going to really
be tight
as to when and how we get out of this
and the r rate is now thought to be
around 1.4 1.5 1.6 it's already
spreading
delaying this by four weeks very likely
means that whether we come out on the
21st of june or we come out
on the 19th of july there's a very good
chance that cases will still be going up
as well hospitalizations and as may
deaths
and so it's going to be a difficult
argument to make at any point and the
fact that they
more or less chickened out making the
argument now and have delayed it by four
weeks
it's worrying to me i mean i i hope
they're gearing up to make it they may
well be gearing up to make it but
i just can't have the same level of
optimism because they're not telling us
what data
they're following and if they were
willing to do that i think a lot of
people myself included would be more
sympathetic to the decision that they've
made
fraser we have had michael gove this
week in various broadcast interviews not
just saying he is pretty confident
though
not too long ago apparently he was
saying he would bet on june 21st
but also being pressed from how many
deaths would be acceptable a day from
covert
and ultimately suggesting that from july
19th
the government is just going to have to
live with it do you believe him
do you think when the government talks
about terminus date this time it is
different
i'm afraid to say i don't particularly
believe
look i believe they mean it when they
say it i believe boris johnson meant it
when he said
this time last year that it would over
be over by christmas
and i mean that's the problem with with
boris johnson he always
he hopes for things and he he overspeaks
he over promises and you end up being
very disillusioned
i can completely understand why kate is
disillusioned after having the goalposts
moved
time and time again i can see why people
are disillusioned after being given
these
sage scenarios back in the halloween a
press conference on the 31st of october
we were told
showing a scenario of 4 000 deaths a day
way out of kilter
to anything that was even plausible back
then and so i i can see
why you might think well look it was
always going to be a new variant there's
always going to be a new risk and
we're not going to really take any of
this new stuff seriously but i think the
delta variant genuinely is different
genuinely is more infectious and we
genuinely do not know its dynamics yet
but we are learning every single day
about this in two weeks time we're going
to know a lot more
only a few days ago for example we found
out that the vaccines are actually very
effective against the delta variant we
didn't know that when kate and i had a
discussion
last friday but we now know there are
basically
the pfizers like 95 percent effective
hospitalizations against delta variants
and for astra 71 percent in the first
dose and about mid-90s
for the second dose now these are the
sort of necessary information that you
need to maybe more confident
when you reopen and that's what i'm
talking about just waiting
another couple of weeks to get that data
to say more
with confidence um so i am not um
the f if i was you know it's funny when
you work out try to work out
do i support the extension am i for
antioch down log down
i don't think anybody can really be
doctrinaire on this
there are certain for example i backed
the first log down because
i thought given how little we knew about
the virus hunkering down
made sense for a while i thought it went
on for far too long i think the
government
and deeply worsened the damage on the
economy and society by not
reopening last summer earlier not
reopening the schools when it could
um so throughout all of this i guess all
of us
we try to look around and make sure that
we're not
blinkered we're not locked into any one
position that we do
look at the changing situations and i
guess these are very difficult
situations the government's making every
time
very difficult indeed there are lives to
be lost on both sides it's a balance of
risk
and i guess what we can do is think well
that was my decision what would i do
and when i was talking to kate last
friday and when i'm talking right now
i know what i would do if it were up to
me i would want to wait for a couple of
weeks because i think the date is coming
very
quickly and i think there is a case to
be made saying right
we are going to have an exit wave is
better we have it in the summer
than we pilot upon extra cases in the
winter but this could be quite a big
wave
for example right now if you get pinged
by the nhs
you need to self-isolate for um for 10
days or two weeks
now you know in america if you've had
the virus or if you've been double
vaccinated you don't need to
self-isolate but don't think you're
going to be
infectious but if we're going to have 3
million cases
in britain if that's a scenario that
we're looking at i don't know how many
more millions of people
are going to be pinged by the nhs app
and tool to stay at home the government
needs to start thinking about that
right now so i do think that the delta
variant
is something which it has really changed
the calculations
it's not too much to ask i think for
another couple of weeks now sure the
government might keep us stringing on
i might be joining kate in in demanding
in two weeks time but the government
does go ahead and do a full reopening
but right now i'm trying to keep an open
mind
frozen just on that i mean there are
documents i mean that have been leaked
um cabinet office documents which are
saying that after july 19th some
measures will stay and one the
government is really considering is the
fact that
self-isolating being pinged will stay
and there's a chance and the double
vaccinated may be able to
get off that as they do a test a day but
that doesn't really sound like freedom
or
is that in your view a sensible health
precaution going forward
i think that's difficult normally i'm
dead against um anything that comes into
a system of immuno privilege
anything which would segregate or divide
britain based on their
immunological status but on a practical
basis
if a scenario we're looking at is
millions of people being pinged all the
time
then i do think there is logic behind
the nhs which after all has got records
of everybody who's been vaccinated
everybody who's been told they've got
covert
or the nhs could think we're not going
to ask you to self-isolate
if you if you've had covered or if
you've had a double jab because we don't
realistically think that you're going to
spread it
to anybody else now this is a very
complicated question i can see the
the arguments on both sides here i would
rather it wasn't raised at all
but if the delta variant is anything
like as infectious as we think and by
the way those figures might still be
wrong it might be nothing like
as infectious as we currently fear but
if we are looking at millions of new
cases
we're looking at millions of new people
being pinged already you can see it
um happening in schools all the time
right now it's getting back to what it
was in the build up
to january so i do think people you need
to be strategic about are we really
going to
have um you know several million people
self-isolating
even if there's no reason for believing
but there stand any risk of transferring
the virus to others
kate so i brought with me a few of the
spectators
recent magazines for the sake of the the
leaders that were published
in them this is from the 5th of june the
title on the website was
the vaccines are a game changer code
covet is losing its sting and
loads in here about how cases shouldn't
be what we're following and
i think my favorite was um in our may
22nd edition
why britain must unlock on the 21st of
june because
you know i think it's important to
realize how quickly this debate has
shaped
has shifted within the spectator itself
i didn't think i had to bring
are many many many articles
and leaders and comment pieces on
vaccine passports
or on immunoprivilege something that we
have been starchily against and
this change in rhetoric fraser and the
fear
that you're putting forward makes me so
concerned about
what we're actually going to get back
because even as we talk about reopening
on the 19th of july we are not talking
about real life still i mean i deeply
hope that every business
is able to reopen i hope that we get rid
of limits on gathering so family
reunions can get back together
my friends can have their weddings and
and people can live their lives again
but the prime minister in his press
conference was talking
he was hinting that there may still be
restrictions in place as katie says
we're seeing leaked documents about
working from home guidance about masks
we know that travel isn't going to go
back to normal
probably for years we still don't know
on the 19th of july
what will happen with social distancing
because in a very untransparent manner
opaque manner i should say
they took it out of the road map so
we're still having to fight on the
grounds of actually getting freedom back
now we're having to fight on the grounds
that maybe we should be able to have
more than six people in our home
and now i'm hearing that there might be
a case for immunoprivilege i mean this
is how liberty dies
this is how it fails we don't have
anybody in government or very few
shout out to the mps that are making the
case for these things
we cannot buckle here and everyone is
taking this very
very seriously i too have been in
support of the first lockdown and the
third lockdown because the nhs
cannot be overwhelmed but we've moved so
far past making the case
for caution and making the case for
science and vaccines do they break the
link
between infections hospitalizations and
deaths now moving into well it might be
a bit
practical to take away some liberties we
should be questioning the system itself
if we have gotten coveted under control
then let's talk about scaling back
all of those restrictions that are still
on our lives what are the appropriate
ones if you have kovids stay home
absolutely but is it sensible
for anybody if they are paying to be
legally forced to do
x y or said let's at least have the
debate you know i think people with
far greater scientific knowledge than us
can have that debate but
the fact that we are moving so far away
from it means that the debate
isn't going to happen at all um and i
suppose i just find that
very very sad because people of all ages
from all backgrounds have given up
so much of their lives now so much to
protect their loved ones and strangers
people they've never met before
because it was the right thing to do but
now the primary goal should be to give
that
all back to them and frankly more
especially for young people who were not
at severe risk of getting very sick or
dying from this virus to actually deal
with some
some of those intergenerational
inequalities that that they've been
dealing with for so long
and now we're talking about
immunoprivilege and
you know whether or not people are still
going to be forced
to do all kinds of things on so-called
freedom day i mean if we don't make the
craze phrase or who will
we are making the case all the time but
the thing is we're not doing this
saying like come what may i mean right
now to take for example back in may
when of course i at the time was very
much wanting the 21st of june to be the
day where we end all restrictions
there was nothing on the horizon back
then to think that we were going to get
another wave in cases
far bigger than the second wave when
something like that changes
if it's plausible then i do think you
need to
just change your mind when the facts
change if this is this is what rational
people do this is i don't think
following
what facts are they following they won't
tell us they didn't tell us in the press
conference
and they won't tell us now the facts
which are following is quite it's quite
simply this that until we can be sure
and again
we're talking about two weeks this is
not i completely agree okay
everything everything you say but all
the sacrifice people have made about the
disruption
to society about the disruption to the
economy and i think
it could well i think it will probably
take us about two or three years to
really calculate
all the harm that's been done by these
restrictions which are absolutely not
being calculated or made clear by the
government
but after 15 months here if we're
talking about another two weeks
to be able to say to the public that yes
we're going to unlock now yes
we are ready for there to be two three
million more infections and we are
confident
we are confident that they're not going
to disrupt because of because first of
all we've got the vaccine dated sure it
works with new data variant we've got
that now we didn't have it last week
because we've got the figures showing
that this does not convert to
hospitalizations
we do have our data now we probably will
have it in one or two weeks we'll be in
such a good position
to restore the confidence and is the
confidence that we need to start to
repair
the damage to society in the country the
government the government could tomorrow
flick a switch and say
all restrictions are off it would still
tickle people a long time have a look at
the opinion polls they are saying
that most people want the restrictions
to be extended
now this might seem crazy to to people
who on the more liberal side
of the argument but that goes to show
that confidence is the nut
to crack here governments cannot
legislate to make people
think but there isn't a risk out there
anymore and if we are
going to exit into a massive third wave
a scenario that nobody absolutely nobody
envisaged in the middle of way of may
because we had no idea about the delta
variant
then you do need to um well put it this
way
to wait for two more weeks to get more
to get more facts to be certain to give
people that confidence
i don't think it's too much to ask i
don't think it's a big reversal i don't
think it's a betrayal of any values
is simply common sense and that's been i
think the spectator's position all along
fraser just finally um i wanted to ask
do you think there's a generational
element to all this too
because uh ultimately i suppose stage
free of the road map which
allows indoor dining drinks like one you
recently had with douglas murray in the
pub um
and some actual socializing probably
isn't that dissimilar to what i i
suppose someone
who ready you know has their family
lives in a house
as compared to i suppose what a young
person wants to do which is probably
closer to stage four
not just talking about nightclubs here
but i suppose just the freedom of choice
to
meet new people and things about having
to go through all the steps you
currently have to do
well on that point you can certainly say
like touche or my personal point of view
i'm not somebody who
bothers the bouncers of london
nightclubs too frequently
normal times but then again i am a
parent of of kids
who have been having to self-isolate and
having their their um
education deprived often i think all of
us feel this
in certain ways but again like in saying
that i think there is logic in the
government's case for waiting another
couple of weeks to
think about this more carefully i don't
i don't think i'm acting i don't think
i'm doing this from purse from selfish
point of view i could try to x-ray my
soul here
and work out um is there something about
this lockdown that i like no i
absolutely hate and despise
this lockdown that stops us getting
people back here together at the
spectator where it stops us
seeing the readers that we'd like to see
we're having to we're there's so many
things which i think
are vital and you know for what the
spectator does and in
us in a sort of professional capacity
but for what we
as a society do there's so many things
and other things i won't
bore you enlisting that i would like to
do i would love to go back to see my
and my in-laws in sweden it breaks my
heart that i haven't seen them for 18
months are probably not going to see
them
this summer at all my my kids are will
not be able to practice their swedish
you know everybody has got
a story of how this lockdown has
disrupted them it's certainly true
the people of my generation and who
basically
own their own home have got a family
who've got a garden but lockdown has
affected people like that a lot and
worse
a lot less but it has affected either
those affected by the virus who are most
likely to end up
in hospital or have lived the last 18
months in fear of going to hospital
and it's affected a lot less than the
younger people who for example haven't
been able to do
internships they've been robbed of the
education which they need to might even
school should never have been closed
in this country so yes there is a
generational
aspect in my generation people i guess
people in the late 40s middle-aged
people who are married
with houses and families perhaps it's
affected us less
than everybody else but i like to think
when most people
say what they want for long time not
just for that but for the society
they try to think for the country as a
whole now for a country as a whole i
fervently want us to be able to make the
recovery that israel's been able to make
but israel's been able to make that with
confidence and i don't think
that until the government can assure
people that there's nothing to fear from
a delta variant we're not going to have
that confidence that's what i want i
don't think it can be done by a policy
switch
i do think it can be done by another two
weeks of data i just simply in short
do think it's worth that short wait okay
you get to have the final word
well fraser's completely right that life
is a lot better now than it was back in
february
and and i know that he's following this
data closely closely as we both have
been doing throughout this crisis and
if he were making the decisions and
making them based on caution around
hospitalizations i feel
i feel quite good about that i would
have that confidence that he's
describing
the problem is that he can't and
apparently no minister
who's actually responsible for telling
myself and our and our viewers
they can't tell us what data they're
following they won't tell us
what data they're following and there's
a confidence that's lost with that as
well
we cannot downplay the pain that will be
caused
by this month delay uk hospitality
expects that it will cost
that sector three billion pounds you
know we may be able to go sit in a
restaurant sit in a pub and
have a nice time with a friend but a lot
of these places that are open aren't
being able
aren't able to turn a profit they're
just just
struggling to get by um for the tourism
industry which relies on those summer
months a huge chunk has been taken out
and
they lost so much last year already
isn't that about confidence kate it's
about confidence and that's the thing i
mean
to get confidence you do need to be able
to persuade people that delta
isn't going to be the threat which most
people whether you and i like it or not
most people think
that it is going to be that threat and
as we've discussed i take that very
seriously but i'm not at all convinced
that in four weeks time
the government is going to be in a
stronger position to build up that
confidence when i suspect because of
where the rate is now
cases and hospitalizations will be
rising but the major point i want to
make here
is that regardless of whether you want
to be more cautious a bit more bullish i
think there's strong arguments on
both sides and in fact i really do
sympathize with that cautious argument
make sure that link is broken so we
never have to do it again
we're not being given that information
and meanwhile people are missing out
on major life experiences and they
matter they're struggling to keep their
businesses afloat
they're not able to get married they're
not able to make somebody
not able to meet somebody new if you had
told us two years ago that a month of
our lives was going to be locked down
we would say that is absolutely
horrendous but people as fraser said do
care
about others they care about society so
we've done it on and off
for 15 months we cannot take that out of
context an additional four weeks
is on top of 15 months of already doing
this and it is reasonable
not to say press the button and open
everything not to say
do what you want it doesn't matter
anymore but to ask the government
what data are you following and what do
you need to see what are you looking at
not what
fraser quite rightly is looking at not
what i'm looking at for the coveted
email
what are you looking at to open those
doors and they still won't tell us
thanks fraser thanks kate
if you enjoyed the insight from kate and
fraser remember you can get more where
that came from
by subscribing to the spectator go to
spectator dot code uk
forward slash tv offer to get 12 weeks
or 12 pounds plus a 20 pound amazon gift
voucher
now july 19th is a due june 21 if it
does go ahead this time what will life
look like then
what does freedom day mean in practice
i'm joined now by david navarro
the who's envoy for cover 19 to talk us
through how he sees the pandemic
progressing
david thanks for joining us again on the
show it's been several months since you
were last
on and back then you made the point that
governments should not use lockdown
as a primary means of controlling coburn
19.
so what do you make of the government's
response in the months that have
followed
well i think the uk has has
had some very big challenges to deal
with uh at the beginning of the year
and now uh has managed to
really get to a much better place but i
want to make
one point only and that is
that we do need to find a way
to stop lurching from what some people
call
freedom to lock down
because that's not going to be the right
pattern for the future
as societies work out how to live with
the virus
i i have noticed that in quite a lot of
countries now
there is an increasing emphasis on
the detection mechanism at local level
and i would add the detection and
response mechanism
at local level because there's going to
be spikes
of disease that crop up from time to
time
in many different locations across our
world
and in order to deal with those spikes
you need to be able
to detect them and then to suppress them
really rapidly and robustly before they
build up into big surges and then actual
explosive outbreaks that overload the
health service
early detection of and response to
spikes in particular those that might be
due to variants
is the absolute requirement from now on
i haven't heard enough about this
in public pronouncements from several
western european countries
i'd like to ask them to give more
emphasis
to that basic public health presence
because that's the key
of getting business restarted and
working well
in future it's interesting you talk
about
almost the the how we go from freedom to
lockdown
and perhaps there's some space in the
middle and we've seen it just now with
this four week delay
again we were talking about freedom day
um but yet we're seeing
government documents that have been
leaked about the various things that
might have to remain in place
so self-isolation periods face masks
potentially
a push for some social distancing um
other than that
so what do you think i suppose the new
normal looks like
thank you katie for stressing that this
is going to be a new situation
uh living with covid
and i do find more and more commentators
are beginning to put their heads into
this
first of all the whole purpose has to be
to make sure that life can go on
in a way that suits all
segments of society whilst at the same
time
the virus is kept back and prevented
from coming in and actually damaging
communities so that does mean
continuing with certain activities that
will make it hard for the virus to
spread
if if i had my way i would say
continue with physical distancing
and face masks as much as possible just
maintaining that one meter plus
distance between people especially if
they're together for long periods
and especially if they're in confined
spaces that's where this virus tends to
spread
and could we continue please also with
face masks
i know that for some people they are
really offensive
but they make a huge difference to the
capacity of
the virus to jump from person to person
can we keep isolating when we get sick
and can we also can we maintain good
hygiene
just doing those four things would make
a massive difference
and then the extra thing we've got now
is vaccines
and i'm saying use the vaccines for what
really is needed most urgently and that
is protecting the people
who are likely to die or suffer
extremely
if they are exposed to the virus
everybody who's got diabetes or heart
disease or other
similar illnesses particularly if
they're older
in above 45 or 50 really ought to be
vaccinated but
everywhere in the world not just in the
rich countries
because those are the people who are
most likely to die
and it's this approach of looking at
what people need
what public health systems should be
doing and the best way to use the
vaccines
that i'm trying to encourage because if
we could do it
in that sort of strategic way
then i think we would get on top of this
virus as not just as britain but as a
world
as far as picking up on something you
said then about
ultimately measures that we might need
to keep for longer perhaps
past uh our new date of july 19th we
talked about the one meter
plus rule if we have double jabbed
uh you know most of the vulnerable if uh
you know most 18 year olds by that point
have one job do you still think those
measures
are going to be necessary and can you
imagine a time when
you don't think they will be is that you
know in a few months time
or is that once the whole world has been
vaccinated
well i i mean my advice to everybody
just simply based on my own feelings
having done public health work for some
time
is don't rush
you know britain and other
western european countries have has done
remarkably well
managed to get the numbers of cases
really down
relieving the pressure on the health
system reducing the number of people
with long covet
it's it's great but
don't rush for this freedom i mean for a
start i don't like this
appalachian freedom day that was applied
to june the 21st
because to be free to be able to mingle
to be
free to be able to go to events be
free to be able to travel again actually
requires a measure of collective
responsibility
and discipline and really good
public services now
and that means that for me freedom
comes with organization freedom
comes with commitments freedom comes
with integrated action
and it's it's so not just going
back to everybody can do what they like
nobody needs to worry about this virus
because that that just does not make
sense to me the virus is very much here
the virus is mutating all the time
the viruses mutants will be able
in some way or other to break through
the defenses
that are given to us by these wonderful
vaccines so
freedom is actually going to be
available to us if we go on being
super respectful of this virus and if we
invest in the systems needed
to keep it at bay and the final thing i
just wanted to ask you is um since we
last spoke
and there has been a lot in the media
about where the virus
originated from uh the woohan lablic and
i just wondered if uh
from from your perspective your opinion
of this had changed or
what you thought at the moment thanks
very much indeed i've been involved
katie in
trying to work out the origins of
viruses that are causing diseases
in human humanity before
and i just have to say you very rarely
find out the actual moment when the over
spill
occurred and so it it therefore means
that it's super hard to find the event
that led to the virus appearing there
are
four hypotheses that have been talked
about
uh both within the world health
organization
and within a number of the countries
that are trying to understand what goes
on
i would like to encourage continued
research to explore these hypotheses
it's perfectly doable but i think that
it may well be
months perhaps even years before there
is greater clarity on the origins
i do want us to know where it came from
because we don't want this kind of thing
to happen again
but i'm just simply recognizing that it
may take some time
so no shift in my own thinking but just
a request to everybody could try to take
the heat out of it because working out
origins is a tough job in the best of
circumstances but if there's a lot of
suspicion
then it makes it much much harder we all
need to know where it came from
and we need to approach it with as calm
ahead as we possibly can
right now thanks for joining spectator
tv david
it's not just june 21 on number ten's
mind this week the government has been
celebrating its first bespoke
post-brexit trade deal
the arrangement of australia seen as a
coup for global britain
but it wasn't long before detractors
criticized that it would put
british farming under unfair competition
so should brits be welcoming the deal
i'm joined now by tony abbott
advisor to the uk board of trade and the
former australian prime minister
as well as james forsyth the spectator's
political editor
tony you've been pushing for this deal
for over a year so
did you celebrate when the news came
through absolutely
like just about every other australian i
see this deal as restoring a
relationship that should never have been
broken back in the 1970s
when britain joined what was to become
the european union
britain and australia have always been
family
and always should be family and this
deal is a way of re-establishing
the kinds of family bonds that we always
had
and we'll now have again james from the
uk perspective
uh how big a deal is this because we've
heard a lot about how oh well it
actually won't have
a huge impact on the economy in terms of
growth but is it more a political
i think there are three big implications
of this deal
the first is if the uk couldn't have
signed a free trade deal for australia
a country which is also governed
english-speaking country governed by a
centre-right government
it would have been very hard to see who
on earth the uk was going to sign a
trade deal with
i so that's the first significance the
second is i think this puts the uk
on course to join the comprehensive and
progressive trans-pacific partnership
big trading blocks centered around the
pacific ocean
with uh and i think the particular
significance of that is if the wto
uh becomes uh fundamentally unworkable
because of tensions between china and
the west
i think groups like cptpp are going to
be what countries fall back on
and then i think the third significance
of it is
that i've always thought the domestic
politics of a u.s uk trade deal are very
difficult
but i think after the midterm elections
you might see the bible administration
look at taking the you
the us into cptpp and so i think in a
way this perhaps
paves the way for that deal as well
tony when we're looking at the pros and
cons of this deal
one of the points of controversy here in
the uk and the build-up
has been on agri-food on australian
farmers
uh there's been some kickback uh in the
end a deal has been agreed but there is
a 15-year wait
at times were you worried the
protectionist might stop that
in the uk look uh
i was certainly a little dismayed at the
level of protectionism
in some corners of britain but
look every sectional interest is
effectively a vested interest and
vested interests will always put their
pitch but in the end i was confident
that the good sense of the british
people and the good sense of the boris
johnson government would prevail
um the important thing to remember
is that this deal is better for both
countries
from day one from day one uh
australian goods and australians will
have better access to britain
and british goods and britain's will
have better access
to australia tony is there anything in
the deal that you think
australia would have been reluctant the
government to sign up to
because because there are various uh you
know commitments on climate change at
the uk side pushed for and appeared to
be in it
katie look um obviously we have yet to
see
how the thing is elaborated in writing
but
my understanding is that the uk
government and the australian government
have agreed
that further commitments if any on
emissions reduction will be pursued as
part of the cop process now
as you know i'm not an emission zealot
i would like to see emissions restrained
and if possible reduced but i certainly
don't want to see
economies turned upside down and
impoverished in order to do so
so i certainly think that there's a lot
of overblown rhetoric when it comes to
climate
that said i am a conservationist
um i want to see the highest possible
environmental standards the highest
possible
animal welfare standards the highest
possible labor standards
and i think any britain that knows
australia would realize that we are all
conservationists that hardier
we certainly don't mistreat our animals
and
australian workers get a very a fair go
indeed
as indeed should be the case in britain
is you see it should be very easy
to do a deal between two countries that
have such comparable
attitudes and such comparable living
standards
and that that's why it was very
important to get this deal done
and why it's very important that it was
such a
comprehensive and high quality deal so
um after waiting through a bit of
unnecessary argy bhaji behind closed
doors
that seems to be where uh thanks to the
good work of dan t
and the australian minister and liz
trust the british minister and of course
our respective prime ministers
scott morrison and boris johnson that's
where we've got to
and james i suppose just quickly a final
question or two
do you think that climate change could
be a point of uh i suppose
conflict between the australian
government and the uk government because
we know the two sides have
a lot in common and but boris johnson is
pushing very hard on his net
zero and cop 26 we're just seeing that
g7 uh
so is that going to be something to
watch out for look i think if you want
to phase out
coal australia is is one of the
countries you need to persuade of
the merits of that uh i think that you
know this is going to be a major part of
uk diplomacy and you you saw at the the
g7 summit in cornwall you know that the
importance that boris johnson placed on
and also the fact that you know the uk's
integrated review
describes this as one of uh one of if
not the uk's foreign policy priorities
i i think the interesting question is
you know
to how much you to what extent there are
kind of coalitions of the willing on
this uh and to what extent that you do
everything through uh the the the um
process
look if i could just katie if i could
just make a point here
um china is by far the world's biggest
emitter
china produces something like 30 percent
of global emissions
china is not promising to reduce its
emissions
at all over the next decade it's
promised
to get to ned zero by 2060
10 years after britain and other
countries and to be honest
um china's promises are not reliable
china's emissions have gone up by almost
100
over the last 15 years china is
absolutely relentlessly dedicated to
making itself stronger
vis-a-vis the west and and we need to be
extremely careful
about doing things that are going to
make us weaker
vis-a-vis china and look we all want to
reduce emissions
but to be absolutely blunt with you
there are far more important
geopolitical questions
at issue today and the last thing that
any of us should be doing
is making ourselves economically weaker
because in the end military strength is
a function of economic strength is
making ourselves
economically weaker in ways which
are not going to materially impact
on climate because of the massive
increase in emissions out of china
james the uk government boris johnson
has been talking about china and scott
morrison on his visit here
so do you think that uh boris johnson um
his view reflects a little bit of what
tony's been saying or not when it comes
to that approach and that balancing act
i think there is a china aspect to this
trade deal if you look at ever since
uh australia called for an independent
who investigation into the origins of
coronavirus
china has been trying to use its
economic relationship with australia
to put pressure on canberra you know
you've had uh tariffs slapped on
australian goods bureaucratic obstacles
put in the face of australian exports
i think if in those circumstances the uk
had not been able to negotiate a trade
deal with australia
then i think it would have weakened
western solidarity against china i
always think there's a very important
demonstration here because
uh new zealand has been very very
cautious about criticizing china it
doesn't want to go through what
australia has gone through indeed the
new zealand has suggested that the
answer to the australia china problem is
for australia to show more respect to
beijing
and but i think there is a hope there is
i mean there's a reason to hope here
that if you can say that you see look
you have got yourself into this position
of dependency on china which is frankly
unhealthy
there are alternative trading options
available i i think that would be a good
thing i think i think that you know
australia has woken up
to the dangers created by it by by the
fact that a
economic relationship with china china
will try and use that to
influence your foreign policy and i
think we have to hope that new zealand
will realize the dangers of this too
and just very briefly the other point
that needs to be made is that a lot of
countries are
are climate hypocrites frankly australia
is often criticized because we don't
want to sign up
instantly to some commitment 30 years
hence
but if you actually look at what we have
achieved
our emissions are down almost 15
since 2005. uh canada
which is a climate darling its emissions
are down
just one percent and new zealand which
likewise likes to parade its climate
virtue
its emissions are down only four percent
so
look at what countries do uh not
at what they promise to do and when it
comes to actually getting things done
australia is pretty damn good james do
you think the uk government can learn
from australia on climate change
i think there is an interesting question
about i think ambitious targets do
serve a purpose uh in that
they they force politicians to confront
hard choices that they might otherwise
avoid but but i think that your these
obviously these targets
don't work if countries don't meet them
and and the other thing that has to be
considered is the cost of meeting these
targets now it's all very well for
politicians to say look in 30 years time
we'll do this
but they won't be held accountable for
the costs of actually meeting those
targets their successes
two or three generations political
generations later
uh we'll we'll have to do all of this
and um
while all of us want uh to get emissions
down
as far and as fast as we can
there is a very significant cost to all
of this in terms of
jobs uh in more traditional industries
in terms of the extra cost of
redundancy to renewable power
and none of this can be discounted
tony and james thank you very much
remember you can subscribe to the
spectator for just 12 pounds if you go
to spectator.com
forward slash tv offer and you'll get 12
weeks of digital and print access along
the 20-pound amazon voucher
next if you had enough of covered in
politics
thank god there's the football spectator
economist rob little has been watching
the euros 2021
and blogging daily for the spectator on
coffee house with his observations
who he's cheering for and which
commentators get on his nerves
rod welcome back to spectator tv
so talk us through your highlights so
far wales
without question i think they've been a
revelation um and
there's a misapprehension about wales as
well which is which is basically that
they're plucky underdogs you know
uh and one hopes that they do well but
one doesn't hold out very much
expectation for them
as it happens they're one of the more
talented teams in the tournament you
know they've got people
uh there's down to danny james for
example gareth bale we all know about
aaron ramsey
but also i mean they're able to bring on
from the bench a player of the
worth of uh of david brooks of
bournemouth
absolutely brilliant young player
there's a lot of skill there
and you know they hammered the turks uh
you wouldn't have known me to listen to
the commentary
because poor robbie savage was having a
fit he was very very nervous
but in fact the turks never came
anywhere near them
uh it was a thoroughly deserved victory
and they got a good draw against a very
good swiss team and they're through to
the next round so it's terrific
absolutely wonderful
really enjoyed it and they played with
great verve and panache
and once upon a time you report to ipsa
for your comments on wales so
are you changing your opinion or of that
free football no i adore wales and i
used to live there
it's where i began my career it's only
about
there are nine people in wales uh
who have had an operation to remove
their sense of humor from inside their
brains and replace it with crunched up
doritos
and the joke i made about wales
was that the land it wasn't a very funny
joke was that the language seemed to
have too
few vowels how you can report that
to the police is it's beyond me but
that's
that's another issue i mean the vast
majority of welsh people
are fine um now
in terms of low lights in the tournament
who is not impressing you
who do you think uh which teams do you
think look like they are you know not in
the right place right now well
the fun about this tournament for me is
i'm i'm a lot older than you
and um nine if you'd asked me in 1989
you'd be watching the european
championships
and you'll be watching the game between
ukraine and north macedonia
i would have said who where
ukraine does the soviet union know about
this
uh does yugoslavia know about this the
number of countries in europe has kind
of doubled
since you know i i grew up with football
um
and i i find it fascinating to see how
they've developed as
as countries which is partly what the
diary is about it's
it's more about history and politics and
it is about football um
but also how they've developed
politically uh
in a football sense as well uh who
hasn't impressed me
uh i'm delighted to say every year i do
a list of countries
i lose i've had to put it back this year
for various reasons
um and turkey is always in the top three
um
and i'm absolutely delighted to say that
turkey have been
hopeless in every possible respect in
the tournament so far
sluggish belligerent and useless so i've
been delighted to see that
um other other sides the checks are
better than
i'd expected them to be and we won't
find it easy playing them
[Music]
i was delighted to see the scots easily
defeated
and but live with the terror
that this will come back to haunt me
tomorrow afternoon uh tomorrow evening
and that they'll beat us because they
will as the commentators keep saying
turn up to the game which seems to be an
important thing that all the
commentators
seem to think it's very important that
teams turn up
um it's a remarkable
remarkable idea isn't it that this
football expertise the most important
thing you must turn up
rod little thank you for joining us and
finally
want to fly abroad this year don't even
bother
between the lateral flow test and the
pcr test the mass guidance and the
mansion of paperwork
flying is pretty impractical these days
spectator columnist lionel schreiber has
managed to make it to new york
but wrote about the hellish experience
in this week's issue
she joins me now lionel in your column
this week you said that you've been
surprised as you suddenly found yourself
agreeing with
theresa may what's going on there i
actually agree with her for once and uh
you know it was a relief because i've
been so mean about her
i've screamed so many things at the tv
um
when she's speaking and it was
it was simply delightful to hear her
talking such common sense
you know she's very concerned about the
aviation industry
and the importance of a viable one
in in an island nation uh
she has a sensible attitude toward covid
she takes the government seriously
when it says that we need to learn to
live with covid because it's not ever
going to get back down to zero again
uh and uh if we keep
secretly pursuing a zero covet strategy
we will never be able to travel abroad
again
and is that really the kind of life we
want and i
i second that you know we we
do down airplanes all the time because
of concern
over climate change and i thought it was
important we finally
stick up for them i believe that
uh especially international air travel
is one of the most marvelous things
about being alive today
and i don't want to see it go away now
you're joining us from new york
um can you talk us through what your
experience is like i'm flying at the
moment because a lot of people have been
put off it entirely but
it's fair to say there are a lot more
hurdles than before
well they're right to be put off it and
furthermore the uh
the experience of flying right now i'm
out of out of the country especially
out of the uk uh is a political one
it in fact my biggest problem is that i
become a danger to myself
because this whole situation enrages me
so much
then i'm likely to get myself into
trouble um
you know we all know you have to get a
test
before flying i could live with that if
they took the results seriously
um okay fine i booked my lateral flow
test
with some difficulty because these
things are never simple
you know anything online is horribly
complicated
but i i i managed uh with a great deal
of self congratulations
and i went to the wrong testing center
first and then we
practically ran to the one on the fifth
floor terminal two
to make sure we got to our 410
appointment
the experience was one of relative
efficiency
given the inefficiency of the entire
business
but you know if you believe that the
tests are accurate
and therefore you have an entire load of
passengers who are not
infected with covid19 why do we have to
wear masks
you know and that's even assuming that
they work which of course
they don't that pantomime is
exasperating
and that's one of the reasons that air
rage incidents especially in the united
states
are going through the roof and uh in my
column i called attention to
an incident that went viral last
month in which a poor flight attendant
was uh not only bloodied but lost two
teeth
now the debate in uk government is
ultimately pushing towards harder border
restrictions
than any easing there are no countries
added to the green list on the latest
update
few expect there to be next time and i
think there seems to be this argument
developing
that actually tighter borders
particularly to countries like new
zealand and australia means greater
domestic freedoms it's what several
cabinet ministers are pushing
um do you think perhaps they do have a
point and maybe traveling is just
something that
is nice uh that's what some would say
but ultimately domestic freedoms are
gonna count first
okay that's a very peculiar definition
of domestic freedom
not you know freedom not to be able to
leave your own country
that is more reminiscent of eastern
europe before the
fall of the iron curtain it's one of the
things that we used to feel sorry for
them about
um more than anything that they weren't
allowed to leave their own country
so i don't call that freedom and
furthermore you know
just as in if we believe the tests work
we shouldn't have to wear
masks on airplanes if we believe the
vaccines
work we should be able to fly wherever
we want
and come back home and not lock the door
behind us for 10 days
and we have not the
uk has not given the vaccinated
any more freedom any more rights
than the unvaccinated that is
demotivating
to get vaccinated but most of all it
casts
doubt on whether the government really
has faith in
in its signature program i mean we go to
all this
trouble and expense to vaccinate
increasingly the better part of the
adult population
and yet you know we're still cowering in
fear and can't go anywhere
there is no excuse for making me take a
test
at all to get on the plane there is no
excuse for making me quarantine when i
get home
and there's no excuse for making me get
these expensive pcr tests
um when when i arrived back in london uh
i am
double vaccinated uh i got my second jab
six weeks ago i'm as safe as houses
i'm as safe as it's gonna get and if i'm
not safe
then then we're in this hell forever
now finally i just wanted to mention
your new book
uh should we say or should we go which
uh talks about confronting death and we
have a piece in this week's magazine by
ann wilson
uh which looks at perhaps how our
attitudes towards mortality has changed
in the past year and a half of the
pandemic
do you think that people are now i
suppose more focused or
you could say sensitive about deaths the
idea of death has become something that
should be eradicated around something
that perhaps we just have to accept
well i think the whole covert period has
heightened awareness of aging and
mortality
um and maybe in in the wrong direction
it's made people
more fearful uh more risk averse
and i i wish it were working the other
direction
um if there's any lesson
in my new novel which i hope is mostly
just
exercise and share entertainment um
then it's that we need to be more
intentioned
in relation to the end of our life
and to apply the same kind of intention
to
our old age and inevitable death
as we do to the other parts of our our
lives i mean we plan
we plan to be uh
whatever when we grow up uh we
make decisions about marriage and family
you know we have a sense of direction
it's often subverted
but we don't want to we just don't want
to think about
the the last bit and
the the pandemic has forced us to
to think a little more about the the
last bit because it's been up in our
face in
broadcast newscasting and i
to agree if if if we if we apply that
greater awareness in a positive way
that's that's not a bad thing
if we instead just become more and more
terrified uh well that's just
that's just a formula for not just
living and then dying but not living at
all
lana shriver thank you very much and
thanks to all of our guests on this
episode and to you for watching
as ever if you have any feedback please
email at spectatortv
at spectator.codyk we do read all of
them
even if we may not have time to get back
to you and a final reminder
if you enjoyed the discussion today why
not pick up the magazine
or read us online you'll get more of the
same intelligent contributors fresh
topics and insightful analysis
without bumping into a payable just go
to spectator dot code uk
forward slash voucher to subscribe 12
issues for 12 pounds and you guessed it
a 20 pound
amazon gift voucher thanks for watching
spectator tv
see you next week
[Music]
you